- The reason that True the
Vote's research, I think,
is so powerful here is
they set such a high bar,
10 or more drop
boxes, because, see,
let's say that they had set
a bar of two drop boxes.
Now, nobody has a
reason to go to two.
Even if you have your
family members' ballots,
you're gonna go put
'em in one drop box,
but some guy was gonna
come forward and say, well,
you know what?
I put my ballots
in the first box.
I had to tie my shoe
at the second box.
So, you're calling me
a mule. I'm not a mule.
So instead of all this nonsense,
set a bar of 10 or
more drop boxes.
Let's remember, these aren't,
this isn't the Post Office.
This isn't where you go
to drop your bills off.
These are only for ballots.
There's no other reason
to go to these drop boxes,
other than to dump ballots.
And why would you go to
10 or more drop boxes
unless you were stuffing
them with ballots?
(funky music)
- I'm Dave Rubin, and joining
me today is an author,
podcast host and creator of
the new film, "2000 Mules,"
which is out right now.
Dinesh D'Souza, welcome
back to "The Rubin Report."
- Dave, it's a real pleasure.
Thanks for having me back.
I'm looking forward to it.
- It's been a couple years
since we've chatted on camera,
my friend, but I feel that
we have to give a warning
right up top here.
There is a good chance that
my channel will be blown up
on YouTube because of this.
But, I did create Locals.
You launched "2000
Mules" on Locals,
which I obviously
wanna get into.
And I'm honored
that you did that.
And anything that we
cannot put on YouTube
for this interview,
we will put up,
well, I'll just say it,
we'll put it up on both
our channels, fair enough?
- I mean, Dave, what a
surreal time we live in.
I don't think you and I
would've predicted a decade ago
that we would find that
these basic liberties,
which are supposed to be
outside the bounds of politics,
free speech rights, for example,
would somehow be
abridged in this way,
and we'd have to watch
what we say and figure out,
should I put this up?
I have exactly the same
issue with my daily podcast.
And with this movie, you know,
I couldn't put the
trailer up on YouTube.
I couldn't buy ads on Facebook.
So, had to develop an entirely
different business plan
for releasing this movie
as compared to any
of my earlier ones.
- So, let's get into that
business plan in just a moment.
But first, let's focus
on the movie itself.
I was at the,
I suppose it was the pre
premiere of the movie,
which was at Mar-a-Lago, and
it was sort of a who's who
of let's say right wing media,
or whatever you wanna call
all of us at this point.
And I got to see the movie.
I thought it was excellent.
Many people on my book tour,
one of the questions that I
got more than anything else
over the last couple weeks was,
what did you think of the movie?
And I recommended
that everyone see it,
make some judgements
for themselves.
What was the initial
starting point of when you,
did you wanna immediately
ask questions,
like the night of the election?
Or was it a couple weeks later?
What was sort of the
genesis of the whole idea?
- Well, like a lot of people,
I noticed the anomalies of 2020,
and they struck me as really
strange, but once the curtain,
well, once Biden was
inaugurated and then, of course,
a curtain of censorship descends
on this topic, I thought,
man, you know, we probably
will never find out
what really happened
in the 2020 election.
With each passing day, the
event becomes more remote,
and I was dissatisfied with
the rhetoric a little bit
on both sides.
Now, you know,
start with the left,
the most secure
election in history.
And I thought to myself,
even before I started anything
with "2000 Mules," well,
how could you
possibly know that?
And they'd be
like, well, Dinesh,
where's your proof of fraud?
And I'm like, well,
let's say I had none.
I have no proof.
Does it make it the most
secure election of all time?
I mean -
- Right, these are
still separate things.
- Yeah.
You haven't done an
actual comparison of
the amount of fraud
in the last seven
elections, for example,
to show me that it
was the least in 2020,
and yet, that became the mantra.
Now, on the conservative side,
as you know, a lot of flying
theories going about anomalies,
episodic fraud, I mean,
look at this dead guy
who voted over here,
look at that guy was
stuffing ballots over there.
But of course, the courts
in these situations
use the principle that can be
called the but for principle,
but for the fraud,
would the election have
come out differently?
And that's a pretty high bar.
You have to show a magnitude
of fraud, and that was,
I had never felt was really
done, never shown, never proven.
And so, again, I
thought, let's move on.
This is something that
we might never know.
So, it wasn't until
I sat down with
the two principles
of the organization
called True the Vote
that I realized that they
had sort of approached
the election like a cold
case, like cold case files.
And they figured out, you know,
there actually is
a way to go back
and track the movements
of these so-called mules.
And there is a way also to look,
through surveillance video,
and in a sense, take us
back to the days before
and during the 2020 election
to actually see what happened
with your own two eyes.
- Okay, so, before we get
into some of the specifics
of how they used geo tagging
and how they were actually
tracking these mules,
and I want you to actually
define what a mule is,
which you do in the
movie, obviously,
how do you as a filmmaker,
'cause you've obviously
made a bunch of
documentaries before,
how do you make sure that
your own personal opinions
don't override the truth?
Because, to me, that's
gotta be the hardest part.
I think there are
moments in the movie
where you sort of address
that a little bit,
but to remove all of
your bias, for all of us,
is almost completely impossible.
- It is impossible.
And I would argue that
in terms of attaining
that kind of pure objectivity,
that's never gonna happen.
I mean, that doesn't
occur at all,
but what you can
do is try to have
that sort of empathetic ability,
and it's a debating
ability, by the way,
to always see the strength
of the counter argument,
of the other guy's point of view
and import that into the film.
Also, one of my
techniques here was,
I recognize that among the
kind of Salem podcast hosts,
I'm thinking of people like
Eric Metaxas and Larry Elder,
there were a mix of
views about the election.
Some of them, it
was stolen for sure.
Some of them, nah, I haven't
seen any proof of it.
And I had the idea of
importing them into the movie,
having their initial thoughts,
then showing them the evidence
and literally spontaneously
filming their reaction
and then asking them
for their assessments.
I thought, in this way,
it goes beyond just
sort of Dinesh's
singular interpretation.
And it becomes a
conversation about the issue
in which it's
possible that somebody
watching the movie
would go, you know,
I see stronger ground in
what Larry Elder is saying
than anything Dinesh
might have said.
So, by doing it that way, it
does what a good movie does,
which is, it lays
out a narrative with
a range of positions
and a range of potential,
of possible interpretations.
- It was interesting.
So, you use this round table
of the Salem hosts, so,
it's you and Dennis Prager and
Larry Elder and Eric Metaxas
and Charlie Kirk.
Am I forgetting anyone?
Oh, and Seb Gorka.
- And Gorka, yeah.
- Again, and you guys
sort of spurt, you know,
you guys come and go
throughout the movie,
discussing what's going on.
And it's interesting
because Dennis,
I think, comes off as the most
skeptical at the beginning.
He kind of comes around
a little bit more,
but everyone's asking
questions throughout
and, obviously, you
didn't cut the questions.
So, there's some credit there.
- I mean, in some ways
that's the best part,
where Dennis will
say, for example,
hey, listen, you
know, you have a mule,
you're showing this
guy stuffing ballots.
What if you run up to him
right now and grab his ballots
and look at them, what
would you see on the ballot?
I mean, what's cool about it
to me is, I thought to myself,
those are the kinds of
questions that people
in the audience are
gonna be asking.
So, by putting them
right in the movie,
the movie doesn't
have to come back
and answer those questions
because they are anticipated
and addressed and at least
discussed in the film itself.
- Okay, so, for the people
that have not seen it yet,
without blowing anything
major, can you at least,
can you give the kind
of elevator pitch
on the methodology
that you guys were looking at
related to people's smartphones
and where they were going
and just the, the basic idea
of what "2000 Mules" is?
- Sure, the film, drawing
on the work of this group
called True the Vote, a kind
of election intelligence group,
if you will, uses
two independent modes
of investigation
or two modes of argument.
The first one is cell
phone geo tracking,
and that arises out
at the simple point
that we're at a stage
of technology now,
and perhaps also a stage
where we have relinquished
our privacy to a point now
where our movements
can be tracked.
They're tracked because of, not
because of cell phone towers
that are pinging, it's because
of apps inside our phone
that allow so-called aggregators
to collect this data.
And, by the way, it's
sold on the open market.
Commercial companies can buy it.
It's also very valuable
to law enforcement,
intelligence agencies,
but, essentially, if I was
being geo tracked right now,
you could tell for sure,
I woke up in my
bedroom in my house.
I then went to a coffee shop.
Then, I went to the studio
to record my podcast,
and I had lunch with a
friend at this restaurant.
Then, I came home, and
all of that is shown,
not by a single
snapshot of my phone,
but by what's called
a pattern of life.
You're showing the
movement of my cell phone.
Now, obviously, if I gave my
cell phone to my wife, Debbie,
it would show her movements,
but that the cell phone
is making these movements
and going to these locations
is really not open to doubt.
And so, what True the
Vote did is they used
the cell phone geo tracking
used in many other areas.
Their kind of genius idea was,
let's apply that to
ballot trafficking.
And what we're looking
for are these mules.
Now, what's a mule?
Basically, a paid operative
who is handed ballots
and asked to drop them
off, to deliver them
to mail in drop boxes.
And we've been able to
identify, based on a criterion,
actually, a very high criterion,
mules going to 10
or more drop boxes,
some 2000 mules,
and that's where the title
of the movie comes from.
- Right, so, you believe
that there are way more
than 2000 mules,
but you were just
focusing on this group
that had this very
sort of high threshold.
And as you show in the movie,
I mean, a lot of these
people that were repeatedly
going to these drop
boxes, they, I mean,
they look like transients
or almost homeless people.
A lot of them, they're showing
up at 4:00 AM and 7:00 AM.
They kind of look disheveled.
They, in other words,
they don't look like sort
of the upstanding citizen
that's doing their due
service for the country
because they've collected
some ballots for, you know,
some people that
can't, you know,
drop the ballots off themselves.
It doesn't come off
exactly like that.
- Exactly.
Now, in the five
states that we look at,
which is Georgia, Arizona,
Wisconsin, Michigan,
and Pennsylvania, you
don't have the kind of
liberal vote harvesting where
you can give your ballot
to anyone and have
them drop it off.
That is the case, by
the way, in California.
But even in California,
you can't pay people
to deliver ballots.
I can't say to my neighbor,
go drop off my ballot,
and here's 50 bucks, because
the moment money comes in,
there's bribery.
Essentially, the
vote is contaminated,
and even a legal
vote becomes illegal
when money changes hands.
Now, in places like
Georgia and Arizona,
you can only give your ballot
to an immediate family member,
or if you are confined,
to a caregiver.
That's it.
And I think you can see, this
is the power of the video.
The second line of evidence in
the movie is you begin to see
not just cell phone devices
moving from one
drop box to another,
but you actually get
to see the mules.
And I think it's very telling,
because when you see a
guy jump out of a car
at three in the morning,
he looks left and right,
makes sure no one's
looking at him.
It has all the hallmarks
to any observer
that this is an illicit
and nefarious operation
being conducted
under cover of night.
- Okay, so, even for someone
that hasn't seen the movie yet,
they're hearing you.
They're going, okay, so,
let's get this straight.
These guys have the phones.
We're tracking these people.
They're showing up repeatedly.
They look kind of
shady. You've got video.
Now some of them
are wearing masks
'cause it was also during COVID
or they were
disguising themselves.
But, a bunch of them,
you can see their faces.
So, clearly we can figure
out who these people are.
So, what kind of
work have you done,
or is ongoing to figure
out who they are.
And I guess the real
question is, who paid them?
- Right, so they, when you
see these mules operating,
you see that they
stop at organizations,
and that's where
they get the ballots.
So, the mules don't come
up with their own ballots.
They go to what we
call vote stash houses.
And what are they?
Well, they turn out to be kind
of far left organizations,
deeply embedded
in the inner city,
places like Atlanta,
Philadelphia,
Detroit, and so on.
So, they go to these places.
They get the ballots,
and then they -
- Wait, to be clear though,
'cause you actually show
the map in the movie,
you show them actually
going to these places
before they're doing
the drop off, actually.
- Yeah, not only that,
but once they go to
three or four drop boxes,
they need to get more ballots,
so they go right back
to the organization,
sort of replenish, and
then they continue.
Now, it's important to
say why they do this,
because you'd think,
wait a minute,
if a mule is
dumping 300 ballots,
why don't you go to one drop
box and just unload them,
save yourself a whole
bunch of trouble.
Well, the reason is
that the next morning,
the election officials
open these drop boxes.
And let's say the typical
drop box has like 80 ballots,
and then this one drop
box has like 700 ballots.
You'd know right
away something is up.
So, the mules are
instructed not to do that.
They drop five ballots here
or eight ballots there.
That's why they go
on these routes,
and that, of course, makes
them easier to track.
The reason that True the
Vote's research, I think,
is so powerful here is
they set such a high bar,
10 or more drop
boxes, because, see,
let's say that they had set
a bar of two drop boxes.
Now, nobody has a
reason to go to two.
Even if you have your
family members' ballots,
you're gonna go put
'em in one drop box.
But some guy was gonna
come forward and say, well,
you know what, I put my
ballots in the first box.
I had to tie my shoe
at the second box.
So, you're calling me
a mule. I'm not a mule.
So, instead of
all this nonsense,
set a bar of 10 or
more drop boxes.
Let's remember these aren't,
this isn't the Post Office.
This isn't where you go
to drop your bills off.
These are only for ballots.
There's no other reason
to go to these drop boxes
other than to dump ballots.
And why would you go to
10 or more drop boxes
unless you were stuffing
them with ballots?
So, that's the sort of
technological reasoning
behind the power of the
geo tracking evidence.
Now, I wish we had more video,
but True the Vote does have
4 million minutes of video.
So they have a lot,
but unfortunately, a lot of
drop boxes don't have video.
- Right, so, are they going
through more video now?
Because there is,
you have some people,
you have their faces, I mean,
have they been doing any
work to track these people?
Do you know where any
of these people are?
I mean, again, a lot of them
sort of seem like transients
or just probably unidentifiable
for one reason or another,
but there's gotta be some way
to get some of them, right?
- Well, here's the key point.
I mean, obviously you're right.
Some of these mules are visible.
You can see their face, and
they can be recognized that way.
But the more important thing
is that True the Vote has
the cell phone IDs of all the
mules, all the 2000 mules.
So, when you track a cell phone,
each cell phone has a unique
kind of digital fingerprint,
the cell phone ID.
Each cell phone has only one ID.
And it's about as good,
technologically, as having,
you know, a finger, human
fingerprint or even human DNA.
It has the same
degree of reliability.
Now, interestingly, True
the Vote doesn't have
the names of these mules,
but law enforcement,
they unmask these cell
phones all the time.
So, unmasking simply means you
go to a judge, you say, hey,
listen, I've got these guys
at 10 or more drop boxes,
so I have probable cause.
The judge goes,
here's a warrant.
You go to the cell
phone provider.
They give you the
names of all the mules,
and then you go interview them.
You know, who paid you,
who put you up to it and so on.
- So where are you
at in that process?
- So, where we are
is that True the Vote
has been working hard
with the state of Georgia,
but there's a very subtle
and complex investigation,
and it's not clear that
the secretary of state,
Raffensperger, who's
leading this investigation,
is trying to push it
forward or hold it back.
He's involved in a very complex
politics inside of Georgia.
Now, in Yuma County, Arizona,
the sheriff just announced,
unknown to us, that
there's a new investigation
into criminal ballot
trafficking in Yuma.
And this is, of course,
important because, in the movie,
we interview a mule.
Where is she from?
San Luis, inside of Yuma County.
True the Vote has done
work in Yuma for months.
So while the sheriff goes,
I'm not doing it because
of a movie, and frankly,
we wouldn't want him
to say any differently,
here is a guy who has
been checking into this
and, in a sense,
it provides a certain
independent validation
that this is a legitimate issue.
This kind of ballot
trafficking does go on,
and it is a crime.
- What has been sort
of what you would say
is the most legit criticism
of the movie that you've seen?
You know, I've seen a
lot of just sort of, oh,
here's Dinesh
peddling the big lie.
Actually, like a minute
before we connected on Skype,
I saw that you tweeted out,
it was a criticism from,
I think it was like
a former FBI guy,
who basically just said,
oh, Dinesh's big lie movie's
going to the theaters,
but there's no
criticism of the movie.
It's just sort of this
blanket criticism,
but I'm sure you've
heard some things
that have brought up issues,
or maybe things that you wish
you addressed, et cetera.
- There are two very plausible
and legitimate criticisms,
and I've tried to address both.
One was brought
up by Megyn Kelly,
and it was basically this.
Where do the ballots come from?
So, in other words,
we know that they come
from the nonprofits,
but where do the
nonprofits get 'em?
- [Dave] Yeah.
- Are these legal votes
that are being delivered
in an illegal way, or
are these fraudulent
and illegal votes
in the first place
that are also being delivered
in a fraudulent way?
- And Dennis sort of brings
that up in the movie,
doesn't he, as well?
- Yeah, we address this
directly in the movie.
And what we say is, in a
sense, we cannot know for sure,
because we're tracking the
ballot from the drop box back,
and we know the origination
point is the nonprofit.
So, we know the nonprofits
are paying the mules.
Now, where do the
nonprofits get the ballots?
Now, the problem here is this.
I cannot think, if you were
talking about a hundred ballots,
I could say, well,
you know what,
some nonprofit went
through a housing complex,
they collected
everybody's ballot,
but we're talking about
hundreds of thousands of ballots
being collected in
five separate states.
So, I say to myself,
what is the plausible
scenario of a legal voter,
say Dave Rubin or Dinesh
saying, you know what?
I'm feeling a little lazy today.
I don't want to go down
the mail in drop box,
I'm gonna go to a left wing
nonprofit in the inner city,
give them my lawful ballot
so they can hire a mule
to go in the middle
of the night,
wearing gloves and take photos
of the ballots going in.
It makes no sense.
So there's, I cannot
think of any plausible way
for these to be
all legal ballots.
So, my guess is it's a mixture
of legal and illegal ballots,
but all these ballots
are rendered fraudulent
by the simple fact that
the mules are being paid,
and that paid ballot
trafficking is illegal
in all 50 states.
- So, you mentioned the
take a picture thing.
So, that is one of
the interesting things
that many times,
almost every time,
the way they get paid is
they have to take a picture
as they're putting
the ballots in.
Otherwise, obviously,
for all they know,
the nonprofit thinks
that they're just dumping
the ballot somewhere.
Would there be any other
reason to take a picture?
I mean, is there any reason
someone might take, I mean,
other than for Instagram
purposes or something?
- Well, this is the key point.
So Washington Post,
Philip Bump and others
have basically said,
it's not uncommon for
people to take selfies
to show that they voted.
They're really proud
of their citizenship.
They wanna show that
they've participated,
but see, that involves
taking a picture of yourself.
- Right, 'cause, right.
- In the movie, you see the
mule standing behind the camera,
taking a photo of
the ballot going in.
So, again, you have to, and
the same thing with the gloves.
If there were gloves from
early voting, October 1,
all the way through the
Georgia runoffs, January 5th,
then you'd go, well,
maybe it's COVID.
But when you see that
there are no gloves
all the way in early
voting and on election day,
and the gloves only show
up in the Georgia runoffs
immediately following
an indictment in Arizona
where the FBI busts a criminal
ring of ballot traffickers
by finding their fingerprints
on multiple ballots.
Well, which theory is a better
explanation of those facts?
The COVID theory or the
theory that the word went out
among the mules,
guys, you better start
wearing latex gloves?
- What should we know
about these nonprofits
and sort of where they're
getting their funding
and are they coordinating
it with each other?
I mean, are they, is
this just, you know,
these happen to be a
bunch of left wing things
that are all kind of
doing the same thing?
I mean, do we know how
connected they are?
- Well, what's really
interesting, Dave,
and we have Scott Walter
from Capital Research Center,
in the movie, talks about this.
A big river of cash goes to
these left wing nonprofits
right before the election.
And this is a little bit strange
because nonprofits
are by law forbidden
from engaging in
explicit electioneering.
They can generally exhort
people, be a good citizen,
get out and vote,
but they're not allowed
to do any politicking
that will benefit any
particular candidate or party.
And the IRS could not be
more clear about this.
So, why would you have
this large river of cash
coming from all these
foundations, coming from Soros,
coming from Warren Buffett,
flowing into these nonprofits,
when these nonprofits are
supposed to, as I say,
be neutrals in the
election process?
So, I don't see this
as a quote conspiracy.
What I see, rather, going
on is there's a coordination
on the left and
among the Democrats
to sort of enable the heist.
So, consider, like,
Mark Zuckerberg.
He puts all this money in,
and he uses it as
financial leverage
to get all these
mail in drop boxes.
Some of these cities weren't
planning on having these,
this many drop boxes,
but Zuckerberg is,
you want my money,
you need to put up
all these drop boxes,
and if you don't do it,
you're gonna have to
give my money back.
So you have a private
citizen, unbelievably,
infiltrating election offices
and using his financial muscle
to get, to essentially run the
way the election is conducted
in 2020.
Now, again, I'm not saying
Zuckerberg knew about the mules.
I'm assuming he didn't,
but think of it.
If he didn't fund
the drop boxes,
the mules wouldn't
have a place to go to.
- Dinesh, it was
only $400 million
that he personally gave
to fortify the election.
Are you saying $400 million
might have ticked
this thing a little?
- Dave, you got,
you're talking to a guy
who spent eight months
in overnight confinement
for giving $20,000
to a college friend of mine.
I was found in violation of
the campaign finance laws.
I was basically, you
know, locked up overnight.
So, when I see the
amount of money
that these guys are able to
put in, now, quite frankly,
the, part of the genius
of what Zuckerberg did is
I can't find a law that
says you can't do that.
I think, in a way, the
audacity of that move
is that nobody even anticipated
that actual state laws
that govern elections could
somehow be manipulated
from the outside,
by a guy coming in,
essentially, with a
sack full of cash.
So, see all of that
enabled the heist,
but it doesn't mean
there was a heist.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlist,
all right, over here,
and to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.